zdf heute live einen schönen guten abend
seit einem monat beherrschen die taliban
die afghanische hauptstadt kabul und die
lage im land ist in vielerlei hinsicht
verheerend sowohl was die allgemeinen
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen zustände
angeht aber insbesondere auch was die
situation der frauen vor ort betrifft
von ihnen versuchen einige verzweifelt
mehr oder weniger ihre in den letzten
beiden jahrzehnten so hart erkämpften
rechte zu behalten die ihnen die taliban
so aber nicht gewähren wollen eine von
diesen starken frauen ist sarah nabi die
wir ihnen jetzt gerne kurz vorstellen
wollen sarah arbeitet als journalistin
in afghanistan fertig dort unter anderem
berichte an beobachtet seit jahren die
lage in kabul und im ganzen land die
bedingungen werden sie werden für sie
seit der machtübernahme der taliban
immer schwerer bei der pressekonferenz
der taliban ist sie als einzige frau
anwesend und hat sogar gelegenheit eine
frage zu stellen
und wir sind sehr froh dass wir jetzt
ein paar fragen stellen können guten
abend sarah nah wie schön dass sie bei
uns sind
ihr habt schönen guten abend ich freue
mich auch sehr und danke ihnen recht
herzlich dass sie mir die möglichkeit
geben mit ihnen zu sprechen und so meine
stimme gehör zu verschaffen
gegenüber anderen menschen in der welt
vielen dank dafür das machen wir sehr
gerne wir haben gerade gesehen dass sie
auf der pressekonferenz die einzige frau
war waren die also dort den taliban eine
frage stellen durfte was haben sie
gefragt
also ich habe folgende frage gestellt
ich habe die taliban gefragt sie es
frauen erlauben werden für die medien zu
arbeiten
journalistinnen zum beispiel und welchen
plan sie haben für die frauen und für
die möglichkeit dass frauen weiterhin in
den medien zu arbeiten denn die taliban
haben ja gesagt gut vielleicht können
die frauen weiterhin als lehrerinnen
oder als ärztinnen sprecht erarbeiten
können aber ich habe gefragt was ist
denn mit den anderen frauen die zum
beispiel in den medien arbeiten da
arbeiten sehr sehr viele frauen und die
haben jetzt alle keinen job mehr die
sind jetzt alle arbeitslos und
und die
rundfunkanstalten die gehören ja jetzt
den taliban die staatlichen
rundfunkanstalten wurden ja auch jetzt
von den taliban übernommen und die sagen
wenn man als frauen für die medien
arbeiten möchte das wird nicht
zugelassen und sie haben jetzt schon
angekündigt dass journalistinnen auch
keine berichte mehr verfassen dürfen und
deswegen habe ich die frage gestellt bei
der pressekonferenz dann haben sie aber
nicht geantwortet haben sie gesagt da
müssen sie warten auf die antwort und
auch andernorts habe ich dieselbe frage
gestellt da wurde immer wieder
geantwortet da müssen sie warten habe
ich noch keine antwort darauf ja das ist
natürlich nicht besonders
zufriedenstellend wie hat sich denn ihr
leben jetzt im letzten monat seit dem
die taliban die macht übernommen haben
konkret verändert
ob alkohol
es wäre schön wenn es an bord gebe ihnen
zu beschreiben wie sich mein leben
verändert hat ich kann ihnen höchstens
ein beispiel geben wie fühlen sie sich
wenn der tag endet und die nacht
ich kann ihnen gar nicht beschreiben wie
sich mein leben verändert hat auch das
wort wandel trifft ist noch nicht mal
das ist kein wandel das ist ein
unterschied wie tag und nacht das ist
selbst auch wenn jemand stirbt
jemand lebt in einem schönen land man
verfügt über alles und von heute auf
morgen ist alles
weg und das ist so als würde man sich
über nacht in einer wüste wiederfinden
wir sind immer noch in einer
schockstarre
bevor die taliban die macht ergriffen
haben hatten wir hier ein normales leben
wir hatten auch hoffnung in die zukunft
wird gut in einem jahr mache ich
vielleicht was anderes und dann kamen
die taliban an die macht und wir hatten
auch juni die vorstellung dass die
internationale gemeinschaft vielleicht
das land verlassen würden und plötzlich
haben die taliban die macht übernommen
von heute auf morgen und das war ein
echter schock es ist wirklich
schockierend und wir sind immer noch in
schock manchmal sagen wir das muss ein
witz sein das kann nicht wahr sein das
sind die menschen um mich herum die
immer noch sagen das kann überhaupt
nicht sein
und man sagt dann auch warum ist dann
die internationale gemeinschaft jetzt
weg und kann es denn wirklich sein dass
die taliban jetzt auf einmal wieder hier
und er macht sind so wie das vor 20
jahren der fall war bleibt die auf
einmal jetzt im jahr oder 5 jahre oder
zehn jahre an der macht die meisten
leute fragen sich was passiert jetzt
alle fragen sich das gegenseitig wenn
man fragt sich weißt du denn was
passiert was wird jetzt passieren die
banken sind geschlossen
unsere unser geld nicht dran dass die
grenzen sind geschlossen wir können aus
dem land nicht raus was wird passiert
werden die uns töten wenn die das wollen
dann werden die auch töten und das ist
wirklich alles sehr schockierend
es wurde alles über nacht zerstört wir
haben 20 jahre investiert wir haben
investiert in die bildung wir haben
investiert in unserem leben in unserem
beruf und jetzt haben wir festgestellt
dass alles verloren ist und
zum beispiel das ist so als würde ein
kind für was beten und auf einmal wird
es über nacht alles zunichte gemacht für
warst du lange gebetet hast du fast 20
jahre lang aufgebaut ist und für was so
gehofft hat ich kann es gar nicht in
worte fassen wie sich unser leben
geändert hat das leben eines jeden einer
jeden hat sich geändert wirklich ja das
kind sehr bedrückend so wie sie das ja
auch gerade noch mal schildern sehr
plastisch die frage die sie auch gerade
quasi schon angesprochen haben diesen
schock den sie beschreiben hat uns auch
marc m über youtube noch einmal
vermittelt warum hat denn die
afghanische armee so schnell kapituliert
obwohl sie doch materiell und auch
personell den taliban überlegen war
haben sie eine erklärung dafür wie es
sein konnte dass das land so schnell
jetzt doch an die taliban zurückgefallen
ist
bevor die taliban niqab buhl eingenommen
haben die hauptstadt bin ich in einigen
provinzen gereist die schon unter der
kontrolle der taliban war ich war in
einer provinz
und einige bereiche waren in der hand
der taliban
ich bin in die bereiche gegangen die von
den soldaten kontrolliert und die haben
geweint die haben gesagt wir haben zwar
alles aber wir dürfen die taliban nicht
niederschießen die haben gesagt wir
haben eigentlich schon munition sind
auch stark ich könnte auch mit denen
kämpfen aber ich darf nicht gegen die
kämpfen und der kommandant sagt nein du
darfst nicht bekämpfen du ziehst dich
einfach zurück das heißt die taliban
rücken vor und wir müssen den die
gebiete überlassen ich habe auch mit
einer dame gesprochen auswahl anschauen
die hat mir gesagt irgendjemand hat uns
hier verraten irgendjemand hat uns
verkauft
denn wenn man selbst nicht kämpfen darf
dann hat es doch wohl jemand verraten
und diese armen soldaten haben gesagt
wir sind eigentlich schon stark genug
die taliban sind uns eigentlich
unterlegen wir sind 1000 diesen und 20
wir könnten schon eigentlich gegen die
kämpfen aber wir dürfen nicht gehen die
kämpfen und deswegen haben alle gesagt
irgendwas läuft da schief
irgendjemand noch
immer hat uns verkauft irgendwas ist
läuft da schief die soldaten haben
eigentlich schon munition dürfen aber
anscheinend nicht kämpfen
manchmal haben sie auch
unsere soldaten hatten eigentlich schon
genug munition und alles und hätten
kämpfen können aber irgendjemand hat
denen ihr geholfen und hat denen auch
gesagt unseren soldaten gesagt sie
müssen das
gebiet den taliban überlassen dass man
ansonsten das eigene leben verliert wenn
es wirkliche kämpfe gegeben hätte dann
hätten die taliban das land nicht
übernehmen können aber den meisten
gebieten mussten sie gar nicht kennt wie
die haben einfach die gegen den
übernommen und so sind sie direkt nach
kabul vorgestoßen und in kabul habe ich
sie auch gesehen da gab es keine einzige
munition die verfeuert wurde es war spät
am nachmittag und wir waren selbst im
schock wie der präsident dann selbst auf
einmal kabul verlassen hat und wir
hatten genug soldaten und wir hatten
alles und der präsident wendet sich auf
einmal an die nation und flieht aus dem
land verlässt das land und als wir das
in den medien verfolgt haben konnten wir
es nicht glauben dass die taliban
wirklich in kabul angekommen war und da
haben wir gesagt da läuft irgendein
spiel und es läuft immer noch irgend
spiel hinter den kulissen und so sieht's
jetzt aus aber wer weiß nach einem jahr
oder in der zukunft werden wir dann
herausfinden wer dieses spiel gespielt
hat und wer da hinter den kulissen die
strippen gezogen hat wir werden
irgendwann wissen aber jeder weiß dass
es irgendein spiel war das da gespielt
wurde und das spiel hat das volk
zerstört jetzt haben wir hier all diese
menschen millionen und abermillionen von
menschen die in den grenzen afghanistans
festsitzen die noch nicht mal an ihr
geld heran kommen denn die banken sind
ja geschlossen ich weiß jetzt nicht wer
mit diesen namen menschen gespielt hat
aber das wird sich schon irgendwann raus
stellen in der tat sehr interessante und
wichtige fragen die natürlich
hoffentlich dann noch in den nächsten
wochen und monaten beantwortet werden
können welche absprachen ist da auch
immer auf höherer ebene gegeben haben
könnte vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz auf
ihre persönliche situation zurückkommen
sie können momentan als journalistin
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
nicht mehr arbeiten wovon leben sie im
moment
das betrifft ja nicht nur mich selbst
das gilt ja für alle leute hier also
heute abend habe ich mitten im taxi
fahrer gesprochen zum beispiel und der
hat auch gesagt ja wir haben jetzt alle
kein geld mehr wir kommen an unser geld
nicht ran oder wir haben unseren job
verloren also ich hab das auch mit dem
im taxi besprochen und wir haben gesagt
wenn das länger als einen monat so
weitergeht dann müssen wir uns entweder
selbst gegenseitig töten oder
gegenseitig auf essen oder was auch
immer also das ist echt hart wir haben
keinen job mehr wir sind arbeitslos und
wir sind hoffnungslos wir haben nichts
in der zukunft was besser wäre und alles
ist geschlossen und die regierung hat
gesagt man kann zu den regierungsämtern
gehen gut aber ich habe vor ein paar
tagen schon mal gehört dass da jemand
zum ministerium für wirtschaftliche
angelegenheiten gegangen ist da standen
taliban wächter davor und er hat niemand
rein gehen und jetzt gibt es neue
beschäftigte die dort arbeiten in den
ämtern und er hat gesagt das ist jetzt
alles geschlossen sie müssen wieder nach
hause das heißt alle haben ihren
arbeitsplatz verloren und das gilt ja
auch für mich klar alle haben keinen job
mehr aber insbesondere bei den medien da
warst ja vor den taliban so dass wir
über 100
medieneinrichtungen hatten hier hatten
wir unheimlich viel investiert viele
viele leute haben hier gearbeitet eine
medienstation hatte 1000 angestellte die
haben jetzt alle ihren job verloren und
alle rundfunkanstalten haben jetzt
geschlossen und alle haben ihren
arbeitsplatz verloren oder die wurden
von den taliban übernommen und das heißt
wir wissen gar nicht was passiert in den
nächsten zwei drei monaten einer meiner
nachbarn ist ein arzt der sitzt jetzt
auch zu hause ob es jetzt taxis oder
nachts wenn er mich sieht dann sagt er
sei weißt du wie lange die taliban
bleiben ich warte bis die wieder
wechseln bleiben die einen monat oder
bleiben die ein jahr abi land bleiben
die glaubst du sara sachs mehr weil wir
können so lange nicht mehr arbeiten und
wir können nicht weg gehen wir können
nicht bleiben sagt mir doch bitte wie
lange die bleiben dann habe ich so lange
aus und warte ob es zwei monate sind
oder ein jahr ich warte einfach das
heißt wir haben keine ahnung wie es
weitergeht und ob die internationale
gemeinschaft uns helft weiß ich auch
nicht ob die unserem volk hilft das ist
wie so ein dschungel wo die wilden tiere
herumstreunen und irgendwie auf der
suche nach beute sind vielleicht werden
so auch die menschen sich hier irgendwie
in diesem dschungel jetzt versuchen zu
recht zu finden wir sind immer noch in
schock und wissen nicht was uns erwartet
also eine wirklich niederschmetternde
bestandsaufnahme der lage von ihnen aber
auch von anderen ja nicht nur gebildeten
menschen gebildeten frauen im prinzip
betrifft das alle wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe glauben sie denn dass die
taliban sich ändern werden dass sie sich
vielleicht schon geändert haben dass sie
irgendwie vielleicht doch bereit sind
mit ihnen kompromisse einzugehen oder
auch mit der westlichen gemeinschaft
kompromisse einzugehen
wir wissen sie ja ich denke schon dass
sie sich ändern werden jetzt versuchen
sie sich ja sehr gut dort zu stellen
aber nach einer woche oder so werden sie
dann schon wieder die alte härte zeigen
ich glaube nicht dass die sich wirklich
zum guten wenden werden im gegenteil
klar es gab diese pressekonferenz im
außenministerium und ich hab da eine
frage gestellt und mit frauen mottaki
ich habe ihn gefragt ob die
internationale gemeinschaft wenn die
internationale gemeinschaft euch nicht
anerkennt
taliban werdet ihr dann auch anderen die
möglichkeit geben an eure regierungen
mitzumachen auf frauen zum beispiel und
da wurde er richtig wütend und da hat er
gesagt
also die internationale gemeinschaft
wird uns schon anerkennen
und warum sollten wir anderen eine
gelegenheit wir haben 20 jahre lang
gekämpft
wir haben unsere soldaten hier
investiert warum sollten wir uns jetzt
wieder zurück sehen die internationale
gemeinschaft muss uns jetzt gehör
schenken die müssen uns jetzt zu hören
der wurde wirklich wütend dass sich
diese frage gestellt hatte und da war
ich schockiert
und wenn er selbst anderen keine chance
bieten will dann ist das ja schon mal
ein schlechtes zeichen als die taliban
kamen da haben sie gesagt naja gut
vielleicht werden die taliban sich
geändert haben und wir hatten ja sogar
an frauenministerium und ziel war es
hier frauen zu helfen das war ein
kleines ministerium klar das ministerium
wurde sofort geschlossen
und das ist nur ein beispiel
frauen dürfen in büros nicht mehr
arbeiten und noch nicht mal getrennt
also getrennt von den männern ich weiß
dass einige frauen in anderen
ministerien arbeiten die werden jetzt
nach hause geschickt wenn die noch
versuchen an ihren arbeitsplatz zu
kommen und ein soldat hat mich gefragt
warum
protestiert ihre frauen denn so viel
eher bist doch was euer job ist ihr soll
zu hause bleiben
im haus ihr solltet gar nicht das haus
verlassen das ist nicht ihre rolle in
der gesellschaft
ihr solltet gar nicht irgendwie
versuchen bezahlte arbeit für die
familie nachzugehen ihr solltet zu hause
bleiben das steht auch in der scharia
und dann habe ich gesagt wir sind doch
auch gegenstand der gesellschaften da
hat er gesagt sei still du darfst mit
männern gar nicht sprechen da habe ich
gesagt na gut dann beruhigte uns auch
jetzt nichts mehr so war das gespräch
das in der tat lässt wenig hoffnung auf
besserung
wenn sie die möglichkeit hätten würden
sie das land jetzt verlassen oder sagen
sie nein ich möchte in afghanistan
bleiben und ich möchte dafür sorgen dass
ja doch irgendwie ein wandel sich
entwickelt hier
ich hatte die möglichkeit
selbst hält sich die möglichkeit hatte
bin ich sogar zum flughafen hin und habe
dort auch
berichte angefertigt
und da man abend die taliban soldaten
sich mit mir angelegt und wollten mich
da nicht durchlassen und
und dann haben sie gesagt
das land verlassen und dann nur
schlechtes über uns taliban sagen und
dann habe ich ihm gesagt
glaubt dass nur nicht die frau internet
in afghanistan hat sich geändert die
wird nicht mehr weglaufen wenn du hier
bildmaterial gesehen hast dann waren die
meisten läutet am flughafen männer das
waren keine frauen also das sind die
männer vor allem die weggerannt sind die
frauen nicht und wenn man da die bilder
sich anschaut dann hat man gesehen dass
es vor allem die männer waren die
weglaufen und es betrifft nicht nur mich
wir frauen bleiben wir glauben im land
und wir werden den taliban mai zeigen
dass wir hier sind dass wir bleiben dass
wir gegen euch kämpfen und das wir euch
auch nicht zu lassen uns anzuhalten und
das bin ja nicht nur ich bin ja nicht
allein das sind ganz viele frauen
die ganzen frauen auch in den provinzen
die sind natürlich analphabeten die
wissen noch nicht mal welche rechte sie
haben hier in kabul ist die situation
sehr gut ich kann auch schon raus gehen
ohne einen mann ich brauche auch keine
burka tragen ich darf auch alleine auf
die straße aber in der provinz ist das
natürlich ganz hart da muss man die
burka bann ziehen man darf nur in
gemeinschaft mit einem man rausgehen
aber selbst die frauen sagen wir bleiben
also wir werden jetzt freundlich fragen
doch bitte arbeiten zu dürfen und wenn
uns dieses recht verwehrt wird dann
werden wir gegen euch kämpfen ihr
taliban dann könnt ihr uns töten und
dann könnt ihr das land meint wegen
verlassen dann könnt ihr weg rennen aber
wir frauen sind einfach in der überzahl
wir sind so viele für euch und wir
werden unsere rechte einfordern wir
werden das land nicht verlassen niemals
ob niemals das sind klare worte ich
versuche noch mal gerade ein paar fragen
zusammen zu fassen die sich aber alle
sozusagen unter dem stichpunkt im
prinzip addieren lassen was ist die
hoffnung was ist der ausblick in die
zukunft was wünschen sie sich etwas
wünschen sich frauen wie sie von der
internationalen gemeinschaft was können
andere staaten tun was sollten sie jetzt
tun was gibt ihnen hoffnung
also ich selbst es geht ja auch nicht
nur um die frauen es geht um alle
menschen in afghanistan
sie alle hoffen und bitten die
internationale gemeinschaft darum tapfer
zu sein so wie auch wir das sind die
menschen die hier lachen immer noch
obwohl sie alles verloren haben die
leute bleiben hier und sagen wir werden
kämpfen und wir sagen der
internationalen gemeinschaft bleibt
bitte an unserer seite verlasst uns
nicht und wenn ihr schon physisch nicht
mehr hier seid bitte erkennt die taliban
nicht erkennt diese typen nicht an die
medien sind ja jetzt geschlossen in
afghanistan wir haben ja jetzt nur noch
die von den taliban beherrschten
rundfunkstationen alle internationalen
medien sind abgezogen und vielleicht
werden die wände noch hier sind dann
auch bald schließen müssen und abziehen
müssen diejenigen die es noch gibt
vielleicht werdet ihr bald unsere stimme
gar nicht mehr hören können wenn alles
geschlossen wird dann werdet ihr uns
nicht mehr hören die leute können
vielleicht kein handy mehr nutzen dürfen
vielleicht keine fotos mehr machen und
das heißt die taliban zeigen sich nur
noch als freundlich lächelnder männer
mit ihren freundlichen gesichtern und
sagen wir sind moderat und ihr werdet
vielleicht gar nicht mehr die echte
realität von uns direkt hören können das
heißt bitte internationale gemeinschaft
wenn sie die taliban anerkennen wenn sie
die taliban
unterstützen wollen dann lassen sie das
nicht zu gucken sie sich diese männer an
und verstehen sie dass die als männer
wirklich das afghanische volk nicht
unterstützen denn ansonsten wenn die die
taliban an akan
anerkennen würden die internationale
gemeinschaft dann würden hier vielleicht
millionen von menschen ihr leben
verlieren denn wenn die internationale
gemeinschaft sie nicht anerkennt dann
wären sie schwächer das heißt das schon
mal die erste forderung bitte erkennen
sie sie nicht an zweitens wenn sie
wollen dass das volk medizin bekommt
dann geben sie die medizin nicht den
taliban wenn sie dem volk helfen wollen
den afghanischen menschen dann machen
sie das direkt über ihre wohltätigkeit
verwendet über direkte kanäle und was
ich noch vordere bitte wenn es möglich
ist verlassen sie das afghanische volk
nicht bleiben sie an unserer seite
sagen sie dass sie uns helfen gut sie
haben das land verlassen
versuchen sie nicht die afghanischen
menschen zu befähigen das land zu
verlassen man könnte es vielleicht eine
million befähigen das land zu verlassen
wir sind über 30 millionen man kann ja
nicht 30 millionen afghanen das land
verlassen lassen und ihnen dabei helfen
das geht nicht das heißt wenn sie einer
million helfen dann habe sie immer noch
29 millionen die verhungern oder in der
kälte erfrieren und wir als menschen
brauchen eine stimme jetzt ist die
internationale gemeinschaft auf einmal
verstummt die internationale
gemeinschaft schaut auf einmal nur zu
und sagt jetzt schauen wir mal was
passiert wie können sie denn sowas sagen
also jetzt vergeht ein tag nach dem
anderen und die taliban greifen schon
stark durch wir haben ja schon gesehen
was sie getan haben wir haben auch schon
gehört was sie
angekündigt haben und wie sie es den
frauen jetzt schon schwer machen und das
ist nicht die zeit wo man still sein
darf wir müssen weiter aktiv bleiben ja
das sind eindringliche worte wir können
im moment von hier aus wenig mehr tun
als ihnen eine stimme zu geben sarah
navi war das vielen dank für dieses
gespräch und alles gute natürlich für
die zukunft dankeschön
und wir wollen unseren blick auf
afghanistan noch etwas weiter vielleicht
um die eine oder andere facette und sind
sehr froh dass wir jetzt gleich sprechen
können mit unserer kolleginnen katrin
eigendorf sie ist vor ort und das schon
seit geraumer zeit seit vielen jahren
beobachtet sie die region und hat für
ihre fachkundigen analysen und
live-schalten jetzt sogar den
renommierten hanns joachim friedrichs
preis für fernsehjournalismus
bekommen zudem an der stelle seines
gesagt auch wir natürlich ganz herzlich
gratulieren wollen sehr verdient wie wir
finden und wir sagen einen schönen guten
abend katrin eigendorf
schönen guten abend wir haben ja gerade
mit einer sehr starken und engagierten
frau gesprochen die sich ihre rechte
also nicht nehmen lassen will was
glauben sie was glaubst du welche chance
hat sie haben andere frauen sich mit
diesem kampf durchzusetzen
im moment sehe ich die situation als
sehr schwierig und fast ausweglos also
ich bin mit sarah heute auch den ganzen
tag und gestern war ich auch mit ihr
unterwegs und wenn man einfach erlebt
wie schwierig ist für sie ist hier in
der stadt sich zu bewegen frei einfach
auf leute zuzugehen
wie sehr sie auch darum fürchten muss
von taliban angehalten zu werden wie sie
auf pressekonferenzen einfach ignoriert
wird dann sieht man wie die taliban mit
journalistinnen umgehen also sie hat
hier mir dann auch erzählt dass sie nur
mit uns zusammen im prinzip sich bewegen
kann leute interviewen kann das
normalerweise sie sich gar nicht hier so
bewegen kann das zeigt ja schon
welche probleme junger journalisten hier
im land haben journalisten generell es
gibt ja auch keinen sender mehr für sie
also ihr sender ist ja geschlossen der
arbeitet nicht mehr alle frauen die in
dem sender waren sind zu hause und das
gleiche gilt für alle freien medien das
ist schon ein riesen problem also freien
journalismus gibt es hier nicht und für
frauen ist es ein ganz besonderes
problem günther zurück schreibt uns über
youtube solange eine zdf reporterin
läufer aus kabul berichten kann kann es
dort so gefährlich doch nicht sein
klingt ein bisschen zynisch
nun ist eine berechtigte frage also ich
kann jetzt sagen wir zum beispiel sind
jetzt hier in einem gesicherten haus
vielleicht sieht man das hinter mir tor
und stacheldraht also ich würde mich
jetzt nicht draußen einfach auf die
straße stellen und man muss natürlich
auch unterscheiden was heißt sicherheit
also es ist nicht so dass die taliban
die überall in der stadt position
bezogen haben und sich aktiv bedrohen
aber natürlich können wir hier im land
nicht frei berichten wir müssen uns an
auflagen halten wir brauchen eine
genehmigung der taliban ich habe in
masar i scharif zum beispiel erlebt als
wir angekommen sind haben uns die
taliban die örtlichen gesagt ja wir
können dort drehen wir durften auch
kämpfer drehen die sogar sehr offen uns
gegenüber waren aber wir dürfen keine
interviews führen also das ist ja keine
freie berichterstattung insofern die
frage ist berechtigt aber sicher kann
man hier als journalist nicht arbeiten
weil es ist gerade schon angesprochen du
bist von usbekistan über masar i scharif
nach kabul gereist welches sind denn die
größten veränderungen im vergleich zu
vorher die dir aufgefallen sind so in
den letzten wochen
die angst die angst die überall spürbar
ist also afghanistan war natürlich immer
eins
der welt und war auch eines der
jetzt kam was dazwischen ihr wollt es
vielleicht gerade was abspielen
ja wenn ich das nochmal aufgreifen also
wir waren ja im juni zuletzt mit unserem
zdf team in masar-i-scharif und auch in
kabul
die größte veränderung die ich hier
empfinde ist die angst der menschen die
überall spürbar ist natürlich im
straßenbild überall taliban kämpfer die
positionen bezogen haben das ist
natürlich ein ganz anderes stadt wird
dass ich hier ergibt aber auch die
menschen wirken sehr verängstigt man
findet eigentlich kaum noch auf den
straßen frauen die nicht entweder tief
verschleiert wären oder burka tragen die
meisten sind auch unterwegs nur in
männlicher begleitung in vier
stadtvierteln sieht man gar keine frauen
mehr auf den straßen und für uns ist es
auch wirklich schwierig mit ihnen so
einfach ins gespräch zu kommen weil die
haben doch viel mehr scheu mit
journalisten zu reden afghanistan ist
auch vorher kein einfaches land gewesen
und die situation vorher war auch schon
die für die bevölkerung katastrophal
also eines der ärmsten und
gefährlichsten länder der welt
sicherlich aber diese angst und diese
bedrückende atmosphäre
das habe ich vorher nicht erlebt und
ganz besonders schlimm stellt sich das
für frauen da also ich empfinde das
selber als journalistin sehr bedrückend
hier zu arbeiten zu sehen dass frauen
einfach ihr recht auf selbstbestimmung
genommen wird ihr recht darauf
eigentlich mensch zu sein
ja in der tat bedrückend aber da stellt
sich dann vielleicht auch gerade noch
mal die frage wie die afghanen du hast
von dieser angst gesprochen mit der
situation umgehen wie nimmst du das war
wie viele wollen sich den taliban
anpassen sie unterwerfen wenn man so
will was ja in gewisser weise nach so
vielen jahren wahrscheinlich leiden auch
irgendwo legitim ist dass man jetzt
endlich auch mal irgendwie so eine
gewisse form von frieden haben möchte
und wie viele wollen sich auflegen
wollen für ihre rechte kämpfen kann man
das ungefähr beschreiben
das sind natürlich nur momentaufnahmen
die wir hier erleben und ich habe auch
nur den einblick in das was in den
großen städten was in masar und kabul
passiert was auf dem land passiert ist
sicherlich noch mal eine ganz andere
situation weil dort sind die leute nicht
so gut informiert sie sind natürlich
auch nicht so gebildet und haben auch
nicht so sehr von den freiheiten der
letzten jahre profitieren können was
mich hier sehr erstaunt ist doch wie
energisch manche frauen auch selbst
unter dem risiko dass ihre proteste
niedergeschlagen werden hier auftreten
und ihre rechte einfordern es ist
mittlerweile soweit dass diese bewegung
die ja letzte woche auch ganz aktiv auf
die straße gegangen ist sagt wir können
das risiko nicht mehr eingehen unsere
frauen werden hier niedergeschlagen wir
müssen im geheimen operieren aber es
gibt doch sehr viele leute die mir
begegnet sind die hier widerstand
leisten und das nicht akzeptieren
afghanistan heute ist nicht mehr das
afghanistan der 90er jahre in das die
taliban damals einmarschiert sind wo sie
die macht übernommen haben sie haben es
mittlerweile mit einer bevölkerung zu
tun die ihm doch schon über gewisse
informationen über freiheiten und über
an einen einblick darauf verfügt was im
rest der welt passiert also diese
gesellschaft einfach jetzt so
niederzuknüppeln das wird nicht so
einfach glaube ich es gibt widerstand
ich kann es nicht beurteilen wie viele
leute sich wirklich anpassen werden
natürlich werden die leute je härter die
taliban hier vorgehen auch umso mehr
eingeschüchtert aber ich habe wenige
leute erlebt das wird ja immer so von
den taliban vermittelt als ob sie großen
rückhalt in der bevölkerung haben ich
habe wenige leute erlebt die gesagt
haben wir sind froh dass die taliban
hier an der macht sind sondern ganz im
gegenteil wir waren hier heute in einem
park in kabul war ich zusammen mit sarah
da haben wir mit
binnenflüchtlingen gesprochen vor allem
mit frauen die haben uns wirklich
umringt mit tränen in den augen ihre
geschichten erzählt junge mädchen die
geweint haben und gesagt haben ich habe
in diesem land keine zukunft mehr also
damit müssen die taliban
fertig werden und das ist natürlich ein
widerstands potenzial dass sie existiert
dass menschen auch sagen ja ok man kann
gar nicht sagen dass es mut ist manche
frauen sagen es ist pure verzweiflung
was sollen wir tun wir können uns nur so
zur wehr setzen und interessant ist dass
es vor allem die frauen sind ja eine
haben wir gerade eben schon gehört das
war sarah navidi uns ja zur verfügung
stand ein anderes thema offenbar gibt es
immer noch deutsche also thema ist das
gleiche aber vielleicht ein anderer
aspekt gibt es immer noch deutsche die
das land nicht verlassen können wir
haben mit einem bevor wir weiter
sprechen werden mit einem von ihnen
gesprochen
meine familie mein vater arbeitet für
die hat mich hier seit seit 2003 für die
internationale organisationen gearbeitet
in dem haus wo die gewohnten weitere
familien gewohnt die
die us amerikaner und andere
organisationen gearbeitet habe da gab es
eine durchsuchung bei uns wir haben
deswegen die wohnung verlassen wir gehen
bei familien hier untergekommen
ich habe versucht
afghanistans belassen gute luft weg als
die bundeswehr hier waren das habe ja
leider nicht geschafft da gab es überall
check points bei einer kontrolle wurde
niedergeschlagen mein pass wurde
weggenommen ich habe aber mein pass wie
das hoch bekommen wir sind jetzt bei
bekannten und wir wohnen jetzt bei
bekannten wird ihn hier und können und
so untergrund leider nicht gelassen
versuche immer noch durch die politiker
zu erreichen bundestagabgeordnete ich
habe heute weitere e-mails gesendet
ich hoffe dass man uns hier nicht
alleine gelassen an alleine lässt ich
habe eigentlich die hoffnung verloren
aber was soll ich machen ich muss ja
weiter kämpfen und zu überleben
das bringt einen zum nachdenken dieser
junge mann gerade gehört haben der
möchte seinen namen aus verständlichen
gründen nicht genannt wissen erst nach
afghanistan zurück gereist weil seine
familie dort wo wir haben es gehört
ortskräfte selber hat sogar einen
deutschen pass gibt es die möglichkeit
inzwischen ruhiger auf den menschen wie
er das land jetzt doch nach und nach
verlassen können
es tut sich jetzt irgendwann die
perspektive wahrscheinlich auch auf dass
der flughafen kabul wieder den regulären
flugverkehr hat und dass man auf den auf
dem flug weg das land verlassen kann es
gibt auch den weg natürlich über die
nachbarländer aber dass es zunehmend
schwierig geworden also es gibt menschen
die versuchen das über die usbekische
grenze das problem ist sie scheitern
dann daran dass sie dort nicht die
entsprechenden papiere vorweisen können
also ich hab selber als wir in masar i
scharif waren mit einer frau gesprochen
die hat mich in unserem hotel
angesprochen eine afghanin die 2015 nach
deutschland gekommen ist dort auch einen
aufenthaltsstatus hat ihre großmutter
ist gestorben
dann ist sie anfang august nach mal sah
geflogen mit ihren beiden kindern sechs
und drei jahre alt die taliban kamen
dann in die stadt und sie konnte das
land nicht mehr verlassen sie hat das
dann versucht über die usbekische grenze
zurück zu gehen aber die usbekischen
grenze grenze haben sie einfach
zurückgewiesen und gesagt nein du hast
keine papiere also das ist ein problem
vor dem sehr sehr viele menschen stehen
menschen mit deutschem
aufenthaltsstatus menschen die ein visum
haben menschen die sogar deutsche pässe
haben das läuft alles doch sehr scheint
mir unreguliert ab das sind immer noch
doch teilweise sehr chaotische zustände
und man ich wunder mich selber manche
leute schaffen es und manche leute die
eigentlich viel mehr ein anrecht darauf
hätten sitzen hier weiterhin fest obwohl
sie über deutsche papiere verfügen also
da müssen sicherlich die entsprechenden
stellen in deutschland noch viel mehr
tun um das meer ja im prinzip
durchsichtig zu machen und transparent
wie die leute denn jetzt wirklich aus
dem land kommen können und auch
entsprechend auf die regierungen der
umliegenden länder allein wirken dass
man den leuten die möglichkeit gibt nach
deutschland einzureisen vielen dank bis
hierhin und auch nochmal für diese
konkrete antwort beantwortet auch die
frage von alfabet und auch von einigen
anderen nämlich wie den orts kräften
geholfen werden soll in der nächsten
zeit auf die situation dieser menschen
wollen wir gerne noch ein bisschen
genauer schauen bevor wir mit katrin
weiter sprechen es gibt nämlich noch
eine ganze reihe von menschen die
berechtigterweise auf eine ausreise nach
deutschland warten
die bundesregierung hat zugesagt rund
2600 gefährdete menschen aus afghanistan
und deren familien aufzunehmen für sie
habe man eine besondere
schutzverantwortung und die meisten von
ihnen seien noch nicht in deutschland
wie etwa frauenrechtlerinnen
menschenrechts und demokratieaktivisten
und wissenschaftler eine andere gruppe
sind die sogenannten ortskräfte von
ihnen sind bisher 248 nach deutschland
gekommen sie haben 918
familienmitglieder mitgebracht
ortskräfte sind menschen die in
afghanistan direkt für regierungs
organisationen unter anderem für die
bundeswehr gearbeitet haben sie genießen
in deutschland für 90 tage besonderen
schutz und brauchen erstmal keinen
asylantrag
insgesamt sind in den vergangenen wochen
4921 menschen aus afghanistan nach
deutschland gekommen nach offiziellen
angaben sind darunter auch 20 sogenannte
sicherheitsrelevante personen das sind
zumeist menschen die aus deutschland
abgeschoben wurden und im durcheinander
der evakuierung wieder eingereist sind
auch deren auf teils berechtigung wird
nun überprüft
natürlich auch ein genauer blick noch
mal dann drauf geworfen werden auch auf
diese 20 aber das natürlich ein kleiner
anteil der menschen wie nimmst du das
war in kabul welche stimmung herrscht
unter den verbliebenen ortschaften vor
ist seine große verbitterung zu spüren
ja eine mischung zwischen verbitterung
und panik also die mit denen ich spreche
die drängen wirklich darauf etwas für
uns also ich habe das auch heute wieder
in diesem park hier in kabul erlebt wo
wir unterwegs waren dort haben wir auch
viele leute ihre papiere gezeigt die für
die bundeswehr gearbeitet haben die auch
für andere internationale institutionen
gearbeitet haben und die sagen wir
stecken fest ja wir sind hier aus kann
da hingekommen aus kundus aus massa und
haben darauf gehofft dass wir hier
ausgeflogen werden und wir kommen jetzt
hier nicht weiter teilweise campieren
die hier in zelten in der stadt und das
was sie was ich bemerke ist dass die
leute alle versuchen sich an einzelne
personen zu klammern also ich musste
dann auch sagen ich bin damit
überfordert ich kann jetzt hier nicht in
dieser situation mich um 20 30 40 leute
kümmern und deren deren fälle hier
weiter verfolgen also meine kollegin
sarah war auch dabei und die hat von
einigen auch die die telefonnummern
aufgeschrieben um zu versuchen denen
irgendwie zu helfen papiere auszufüllen
meine erfahrung ist dass
die menschen diese
institutionen haben oder persönliche
verbindungen
die für sie eingetreten sind und
wirklich das durchgekämpft haben
dass das die erfolgreich sind aber es
gibt ja einfach so so viele die das
nicht haben also ich bin selber in
kontakt gewesen
mit einer radsportlerin sage ich jetzt
mal ein beispiel die wir porträtiert
haben im zdf die mich panisch angerufen
hat gesagt ich muss hier raus ja wir
haben da wirklich tage lang daran
gearbeitet
mit einer sicherheitsfirma ich habe
unendlich viele telefonate geführt
habe die frau auch begleitet die es dann
zum flughafen gefahren hat mir immer
wieder panisch irgendwelche meldungen
geschickt und letztendlich hat sie es
dann geschafft
aber wer hat er diese unterstützung also
ohne diese unterstützung
schaffen es die leute eben oft nicht
oder es sind eben die die sich
durchboxen die starken ja aber die
frauen mit kindern familien das sind
eben die schwachen und solange es keine
systematischen möglichkeit gibt dieses
land zu verlassen
ja spielen sich halt weiter solche
dramatischen szenen aber und das finde
ich sehr sehr traurig und eigentlich
sehr bedrückend ja das kann man auch
wohl nicht anders bezeichnen wir haben
von der karten in den letzten wochen
viele sehr eindrückliche sehr bewegende
reportagen gesehen unter anderem auch
aus einem krankenhaus in kabul
vielleicht wenn es noch einmal
zusammenfasst wo siehst du momentan die
größten probleme des landes und wie ist
vielleicht auch noch mal die humanitäre
lage einzuschätzen
das größte problem des landes ist ist
armut wie gesagt
afghanistan war schon vor der
machtübernahme der taliban eines der
ärmsten länder der welt wir sind
mittlerweile in einer situation wo drei
von vier familien akut unter hunger
leiden die zu versorgen darin sehe ich
im moment das allergrößte problem dann
haben wir es mit über einer halben
million neuen binnenflüchtlingen zu tun
die überall hier in kabul auch auf der
straße kampieren die nicht versorgt
werden die kein fließendes wasser haben
keine sanitäranlagen das ist wirklich
nothilfe die dringend geleistet werden
muss dann sehe ich ein problem auch im
drohenden zusammenbruch des
gesundheitssystems das war ja vorher
schon fragil und hat nicht wirklich
funktioniert aber jetzt erleben wir
wirklich dadurch dass einfach die
finanzen fehlen dass auch viele ärzte
ihre posten verlassen haben
dass die krankenhäuser nicht mehr
vernünftig funktionieren ich war hier in
einem kinderkrankenhaus und hab mir
macht versucht persönlichen eindruck zu
verschaffen und was ich da gesehen habe
das war einfach nur schockiert das ist
wirklich schwer das mit worten zu
beschreiben
die ärzte haben mich da zum beispiel
mitgenommen auf eine säuglingsstation
da hatten sie nicht genug medikamente um
die kinder zu behandeln
die dort krank sind denn es bleiben ja
nur die kranken da die gesunden werden
ja mit nach hause genommen die kinder
werden teilweise zu zweit zu dritt in
bettchen gesteckt es gab in der gesamten
säuglingsstation nur einem
überwachungsmonitor keinen sauerstoff
kann antibiotika der arzt hat dann vor
meinen augen eine schublade aufgezogener
lagen ein paar fläschchen drin wo er
sagte das sind eigentlich alle unsere
medikamente die wir haben und hatten wir
konkret auch kinder gezeugt hat gesagt
dieses kind hier wird definitiv nicht
überleben weil wir können das nicht
retten wir haben nicht die nötigen
medikamente dafür wir haben nicht die
ausstattung dann gibt es eine extra
abteilung nur für kinder die an
unterernährung leiden da haben wir
kinder gesehen die dann wirklich ganz
grauenvoll aus also die folgen von
unterernährung bei kindern sind ein
gravierendes problem und vor allem eben
das trifft die schwächsten
der kollaps der drohende kollaps des
gesundheitssystems trifft die
schwächsten hier im land das sind die
kinder und da sind die frauen man kann
sich vorstellen die frauen haben hier
sehr viele kinder und hier unter diesen
umständen ein kind eine schwangerschaft
durchzustehen ein kind auszutragen zur
welt zu bringen
also das ist das ist unvorstellbar
schwer und das sind sagen wir mal aus
meiner sicht zu die gravierenden
probleme die ich jetzt im moment hier
sehe also die gegenwart ist ja mehr als
deprimierend kann man sagen wie stabil
schätzt du jetzt die herrschaft der
taliban ein man muss sich ja vorstellen
da gibt es ja doch auch widerstände im
land also es gibt andere
islamistengruppen es gibt widerstand aus
der bevölkerung es gibt noch das nicht
ganz geklärtes verhältnis zu den anderen
ländern drumherum also droht dem land
noch schlimmeres vielleicht sogar einen
bürgerkrieg
das halte ich nicht für ausgeschlossen
also die taliban sprechen ganz
sicherlich nicht mit einer stimme es
gibt ja im moment vor allem den sozialen
medien gerüchte darüber dass es eine
klare spaltung innerhalb der führung der
taliban gibt das halte ich auch nicht
für ausgeschlossen wir hatten heute ein
interview mit dem sprecher der taliban
der sahwa zu der fraktionen
dieser gruppe gehört der er dafür wirbt
mit der internationalen community ins
gespräch zu kommen der auch mit
journalisten spricht der sagt
afghanistan darf nicht in zukunft
isoliert sein aber es gibt auf der
anderen seite auch innerhalb der taliban
gruppierungen die sagen wir lassen uns
vom besten gar nicht sagen alle
ausländischen journalisten müssen sofort
das land verlassen und die ein
wesentlich konfrontativen kurs
vertreten also da ist sicherlich das
letzte wort noch nicht darüber
gesprochen wer sich letztendlich
durchsetzt die möglichkeit dass auch
bewaffnete gruppen die in opposition zu
den taliban stehen hier noch mal bei
kämpfen erfolgreich sein könnten die
besteht natürlich auch bislang ist der
widerstand im pandschir tal den es je
gegeben hat niedergeschlagen worden von
den taliban aber ob sich das auf dauer
so durchsetzt man kann hier nicht von
einer stabilen regierung oder von einer
stabilen struktur sprechen letzte frage
von mir gibt es so was wie einen
hoffnungsschimmer entwicklungen zu sagen
die gemacht worden sind die den menschen
vor ort doch vielleicht so ein bisschen
hoffnung geben könnten
das wichtigste ist sicherlich erstmal
die zusage internationaler soforthilfe
dass man wirklich hier dafür sorgt dass
die internationalen
hilfsorganisationen die im land ja immer
noch präsent sind und arbeiten jetzt
hier soforthilfe leisten
versuchen die menschen an die sie
rankommen zu versorgen die krankenhäuser
weiter laufen zu lassen das ist sagen
wir mal ein punkt der zweite punkt ist
dass wir weiterhin schauen dass wir hier
bleiben und präsent sind und darüber
berichten was hier passiert also das
sagen wir ganz ganz viele menschen dass
es für sie wichtig ist dass jetzt nicht
der westen einfach abziehen und dieses
dieses land vergiss das sind natürlich
vor allem intellektuelle aber es ist
auch ein hoffnungsschimmer ich denke
politisch gesehen ist es ganz wichtig
die chance zu nutzen auf diese regierung
druck auszuüben denn die taliban wissen
auch dass sie international isoliert so
nicht weiterexistieren können dann wird
dieses land in einen absoluten abgrund
steuern und das haben sie mittlerweile
auch verstanden im gegensatz zu den
taliban der 90er jahre dass sie irgendwo
kooperieren müssen aber wichtig ist in
dieser hinsicht auch
dass da viele länder mitziehen also
sagen wir mal die länder die den
haupteinfluss auf die taliban haben
pakistan
zum beispiel müssen hier ihren einfluss
geltend machen und dürfen nicht im
prinzip gegen gegen die ganzen
prinzipien die wir einfordern verstoßen
dass wir sagen es muss menschenrechte
geben es muss eine beteiligung von
anderen
politischen gruppen geben also das halte
ich für unglaublich wichtig wir werden
das nicht isoliert als euro als europäer
oder europäer in gemeinschaft mit den
amerikanern schaffen die taliban zu
einem sammer gemäßigteren kurs zu
bewegen sondern da muss die
internationale gemeinschaft an einem
strang ziehen vielen dank das sagen die
einschätzungen von katrin eigendorf aus
afghanistan befunde kennerin des landes
vielen dank nochmal für diese
information und für das gespräch heute
abend alles gute herr bohm dankeschön
und auch an euch natürlich einen ganz
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen und fürs
mitmachen ich habe versucht so gut es
geht eure fragen mit aufzunehmen in
meine fragen an katrin es war eine
pickepackevoll sendung dankeschön fürs
zu sehen und euch allen einen schönen
abend bis demnächst vielleicht bis
morgen oder übermorgen macht's gut tat